the man of the hour Nevin Mimico came to
Parliament on Tuesday for a grilling by
MEP some internal market committee his
nomination as the ease 28th Commissioner
for consumer protection coincides with
Croatia's accession to the EU and July
the first the hearing was a final test
before his expected anointment so who is
Navin Mimico and is he the right man for
the job fellow socialist gave their
approval musafir Lafitte Gambon
personality Claire Claire fortunate I am
pleased on tsampa see política de
montreuil keep ave verum oh I don't seen
it with your bein a career politician
and long champion of Croatia's accession
to the EU mr. mu cos currently courage
his deputy prime minister for foreign
affairs and EU integration taking the
floor the man from Croatia put on a good
show I am determined to use the full
potential of European consumer policy it
is a real citizens policy it connects
the union to the people in fact it is
often the answer to the basic question
of our citizens what does the union do
for me he talk tough but realistically
can he achieve much he only has seen 15
months in the post the Sunnah me please
mr. mimic a felt a bit flat I've seen
many hearings in my time in the European
Parliament and this was not really not
the best he was very wake very
diplomatic and I think there should have
been more precise answers we have
problems we have challenges we have very
concrete issues and we'd expect a very
concrete plan or maybe an honest answer
post here in the biggest party in
parliament the EPP ever lay down
conditions for miss dominica any Peas
will give their final approval at the
plenary